le baron pain quitte la présidence de
son groupe son successeur run and gun
strict pour la première fois la marée
noire au sénat les mesures du
gouvernement
les volontaires sur le terrain raymond
barre consulte les syndicats demain
premier rang des groupes andré bergeron
est faux la crise du pc avec roger
garaudy les quatre erreurs de la ligne
marché la folie du disco une musique
française qui vient d'amérique
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir du
froid de la neige du verglas du
brouillard de la pluie
et dire que le printemps a commencé il
ya trois semaines déjà en réalité c'est
une véritable journée divers que la
france a connu aujourd'hui avec des
températures que l'on n'avait pas vu
paraît-il depuis 25 ou 30 ans et aussi
de la neige beaucoup de neige autant qu
en plein hiver sur le pas de calais la
bretagne plus presque sur les massifs
comptait ni les proverbes ne manquent
pas pour nous indiquer que le mois
d'avril est traditionnellement un mois à
ses frais alors là tout de même trop
c'est trop
trois semaines après le retour du
printemps il neige il vante 7 avril qui
justifie sa réputation et son proverbe
archi connus
et presque chaque année vérifier il a
neigé en montagne et même dans les
pyrénées en moyenne altitude et en
plaine comme le montrent ces images
et puis aussi en bretagne en normandie
sur le bassin parisien et à paris même
et surtout dans le nord et le
pas-de-calais 25 centimètres de neige ce
matin à boulogne alors que le record
précédent pour cette ville et en cette
saison était de 10 cm en mars 1958
en fait il a fait presque mauvais
partout en france avec des variantes
giboulées de pluie brouillard et autres
agréments du même genre et puis partout
il fait froid un froid qui nous vient du
groenland
poussé par des vents qui soufflent du
nord et qui hélas ne sont pas à bout de
souffle
demain il faudra encore froid le matin
il gèlera ans la quasi-totalité du pays
à noter également des brouillards
givrants dans le sud ouest et le massif
central
les conditions de circulation risquent
d'être très difficiles sur l'ensemble du
réseau
nous tout de même une amélioration
prévue et bien une zone de temps plus
doux avec des pluies abordera dès la
matinée la bretagne et s'étendra dans la
journée à la majeure partie du pays
sur le reste du pays c'est à dire des
pyrénées orientales et central aux alpes
et aux régions méditerranéennes
le temps fort relativement beau avec
toutefois quelques chutes de neige en
montagne
c'est seulement quand tu veux vendredi
que le temps va vraiment ce doux si
c'est ça vendredi après une matinée
plutôt froid de et brumeuse
le soleil brille aurore et les
températures marqueront une hausse
sensible mais le week-end promet d'être
beau alors attendons ce week-end les 130
mille ouvriers employés techniciens et
cadres qui travaillent en france dans
les différentes sociétés du groupe
enfin cheney dhr ont changé de patron
hier le conseil d'administration du
groupe s'est réuni dans le plus grand
secret le baron empain a demandé à
prendre quelques mois de repos et c'est
son premier collaborateur monsieur rené
engel qui était élue à la présidence
monsieur une gaine pendant l'enlèvement
de l'industriel franco-belge avait
d'ailleurs occuper ce poste mais par
intérim aujourd'hui au lendemain de sa
nomination le nouveau grand responsable
du groupe enfin a accepté de recevoir
deux journalistes deux journalistes deux
antennes de jean pierre elkabbach et
philips ac c'est la première fois que
monsieur une gaine répond aux questions
vous allez l'entendre il parle du baron
empain
il parle de l'enlèvement de suicide de
sa libération de son état de santé et
aussi du groupe industriel qu'il
représente 1 qu'après cette épreuve
assez dur je crois qu'un homme normal
n'aurait pas supporté
il était normal qu'ils reprennent un
certain équilibre d'un certain recul
de reprendre des forces il faut pas
oublier qu'il a subie cette mutilation
et qu'il a vécu dans des conditions
vraiment inhumaines pendant deux mois il
connaissait très bien qu'il avait
rencontré qu'il y avait encore vu avant
son départ qu'elle vous trouvez de
changer dans son comportement
il était fortement amaigri je crois que
son son équilibre son moral était assez
affecté et qu'il était nécessaire qu'il
change un peu d'air son départ du groupe
et la suite aux agissements des parts du
groupe c'est un grand mot n'est pas il
n'a pas quitté le groupe il reste
l'actionnaire principal du groupe avec
sa famille et le fait de me délégué ses
fonctions et simplement un acte ii pour
se reposer dix on est un acte normal il
ne quitte pas le groupe
il nous a fallu sanguine et combien de
temps il sera absent le temps de se
reprendre de se remettre en effet je ne
sais pas je ne suis pas médecin je n'ai
pas la capacité de déterminer la
longueur mais tout ce que je sais c'est
que nous souhaitons tous qu'il revienne
et qu'il reprenne en tout ou en partie
progressivement ou direct en les
fonctions qu'il avait donc il a été très
touchée mais est-ce qu'il va rester le
patron julia ce que pendant son absence
il va continuer à téléphoner à s'occuper
de ses affaires
je crois que nous allons essayer d'abord
pour que la cure dent de redressement
soit aussi si courte que possible et
souhaitable que son repos soit aussi
total que possible nous avons donc
intérêt à le laisser tranquille comme
quelqu'un qui est en vacances qui prend
de vraies vacances nous nous téléphonons
régulièrement de toute façon et il est
au courant s'il le décide et de tous les
événements importants qui pourraient
survenir
et si la construire et combien de temps
le temps qu'il faudra pour qu'il se
rétablisse et dit qu'elles sont
terminées il le reprend son rôle il
revient dans ce bureau qui juste
derrière cette reviendra normalement
dans son bureau et il reprendra les
fonctions qu'il jugera utile de
reprendre et que je lui garde au chaud
en attendant il va y avoir des
changements 10 ans ou votre région
absolument d'aucun le bar en a pas et
moi même nous faisons un travail d'
équipe depuis qu'il a pris la présidence
du groupe
nous ne sommes jamais quittés nous avons
toujours travaillé tous ensemble et il
ne peut y avoir aucun élément nouveau
nid dans la dans les objectifs ni dans
les structures nées dans les méthodes
qui sont les grands objectifs
aujourd'hui ce début 2009 78 d'un coup
comme le vôtre cessé de faire la
démonstration qu'un groupe privé et
indépendant peut mieux servir qu'un
autre peut-être là l'économie d'un pays
et d'assurer mieux qu'un autre peut être
aussi le progrès social
nous en avons fait la démonstration
jusqu'à présent nous espérons bien
continuer le biais d'une question un peu
brutal est ce qu'après un tel choc après
une telle souffrance est ce qu'un homme
peut reprendre les responsabilités qu'il
avait il a assumé comme le baron empain
il assume depuis maintenant plus de dix
ans je crois que c'est une question très
médicale j'espère que oui
en tout cas nous ferons tous tous pour
que ce soit comme ça ne marchera pas
n'est pas seulement pour moi un équipier
et pas c'est aussi un ami pour le baron
empain la fin de l' aventure aura
finalement été heureuse pour le baron
brac
cet industriel belge enlevés il y a
trente cinq jours il y en aura pas été
de même vous le savez on le sait
maintenant ses ravisseurs n'ont jamais
eu la voulons
et de le garder en vie ils l'ont tuée au
lendemain même de l'enlèvement d'une
balle dans la tête
et puis il ya l'italie l'italie avec sa
violence quotidienne ces meurtres et ces
enlèvements aujourd'hui deux attentats
ont été commis à turin ce matin c'est un
gardien de prison qui a été tué cet
après midi c'est un médecin un
gynécologue qui a été grièvement blessé
et pendant ce temps monsieur aldo moro
le président la démocratie chrétienne
italienne est toujours retenu en otage
par un commando des brigades rouges cet
enlèvement créé un profond malaise en
italie dans le dernier document envoyé
par les ravisseurs de monsieur aldo moro
ce dernier s'en prenant nommément à l'un
des principaux responsables de la
démocratie chrétienne et on se demande
maintenant en italie
si d'autres révélations ne vont pas
suivre les italiens qui lisent les
journaux écoutent la radio et regardent
la télévision sont de plus en plus
perplexe est incrédule
voilà près de trois semaines cale de
morrow a été enlevé par les brigades
rouges non seulement lankais de la
police ne donne rien mais il assiste à
une étrange et machiavélique opérations
des brigades rouges qui consiste tout
simplement à compromettre de façon
définitive le prestige du président de
la démocratie chrétienne auprès des
italiens
aldo moro qui se trouve dans une prison
du peuple pour employer l'expression des
brigades rouges a déjà envoyé plusieurs
lettres à sa famille ou à la démocratie
chrétienne
à chaque fois ils s'étonnent ils
protestent pourquoi est-ce qu'on négocie
pas ma libération
ma vie est en danger est ce qu'on va me
sacrifier parce que le gouvernement a
décidé de ne pas céder au chantage des
terroristes
toutes ces lettres ont bien été écrite
par aldo moro la démocratie chrétienne
affirme aldo moro écrit sous la
contrainte
peut être même sous l'effet d'une drogue
en tout cas on assiste à une véritable
décomposition du président aldo moro le
mot n'est pas trop fort peut-être
qu'elle nomme euro ne résiste pas aux
méthodes des brigades rouges
peut-être que sa personnalité n'était
pas aussi forte qu'on l'a dit le temps
joue pour les brigades rouges peu à peu
et alors que les barrages de police ont
été levées et que la vie a repris ses
droits
peu à peu les italiens oublie
l'enlèvement lui-même pour le conserver
qu'une image équivoque d'aldo moro rome
se remplie de touristes comme chaque
année à la même époque
car les évènements n'ont pas freiné
l'invasion et les touristes qui
s'attendaient peut-être à ressentir
quelques émotions fortes sont témoins
d'une étrange situation un procès du
type stalinien qui se déroule dans la
clandestinité et dont l'accusé
semble jouer le jeu devant des millions
d'italiens stupéfait la marée noire
un bâtiment de la marine nationale a
intercepté en début d'après-midi un
cargo grec au large de l'île d'ouessant
ce cargo naviguer dans ce que l'on
appelle le rail des pétroliers il
n'avait rien à y faire cette
interception est la première réalisée
par la marine nationale à la suite du
naufrage de l'amoco cadiz sur les roches
de portsall cet après midi au sénat
trois membres du gouvernement étaient
d'ailleurs présents pour répondre aux
questions des parlementaires à propos
justement de ce naufrage et de la marée
noire qui lui a succédé
les sénateurs avaient des questions à
poser des questions sur les
circonstances de ce naufrage mais aussi
sur l'organisation des secours
la réponse de monsieur beckham en séance
de nuit et puis durant ce week end c'est
une véritable marée humaine qui a
déferlé sur portsall et sur les côtes
bretonnes pour voir une autre marée cela
une marée noire
les touristes étaient là aussi pour voir
comment s'effectuent les opérations de
nettoyage des côtes sur les 500 km de
criques et de plages qui sont pollués le
travail se poursuit lentement 8000
militaires et bénévoles travailleurs
travaillent huit heures par jour et on
estime que d'ores et déjà 80 mille
mètres cubes de résidus de mazout ont
déjà été récupérés si au début le
travail des volontaires n'a pas toujours
été bien compris les choses se sont
améliorées au fil des jours ils étaient
750 la semaine dernière ils sont 800
cette semaine avec la fin des congés
scolaires ils seront 250 la semaine
prochaine leurs tâches et des roannais
toi man 2 450 km de côtes
en tout donc les directions
départementales de la jeunesse et des
sports de bretagne accueille équipe loge
nourrissent 1800 jeunes
ce groupe de pont-à-mousson arrivé
avant-hier soir découvre le désastre
l'enthousiasmé débordant du départ
disparaît travail difficile ingrat
les anciens ont prévenu ce soir la marée
montante recourir à ce que vous venez de
déployer pour lutter contre courbatures
en foule des pauses fréquentes
attendant la pression de rien faire vous
été surprise quand vous avez vu
l'étendue des dégâts
c'est très fatigant revendre un cadeau
de regretter pas d'être venu non non non
seulement un peu amusant de la journée
la douche tout habillé tout savait pour
l'avoir lu quelque part que le mazout
c'est noir ça colle ça sent mauvais mais
à ce point là non si le travail est
pénible
les conditions matérielles du séjour
sont bonnes affirme le responsable du
groupe nous couchons dans des dortoirs
nous sommes des indices très bien
toujours plus anciens ne partagent plus
cet optimisme ils sont déçus pour eux il
n'y a pas que l'aspect matériel dit
parce qu'il y avait la marée noire pour
aider les bretons on n'a pas trouvé des
chalets breton sur place mais ce que les
bretons monde magique cette marée
ensuite même certains bretons sont
nullement des en aucun cas ces
mouvements que nous en tant que breton a
refusé de faire le nettoyer ce que c'est
pas à nous de faire les bretons ne sont
pas très expansif par nature c'est une
pause c'est un premier point
deuxièmement il faut aussi penser que
il me semble à des catastrophes il y à
11 ans les avait traumatisé et qu'ils
étaient un peu sceptiques sur le travail
peut vous fournir de jeunes volontaires
voilà la raison essentielle de leur
accueil un peu réservé hier soir encore
de nouveaux groupes arrivait en gare de
saint brieuc la flore furent bons sites
où il était véhiculé nourris logés mais
ce matin première épreuve il grellet les
plages bretonnes
monsieur marc bécane qui comme tous les
secrétaires d'état participera demain à
la réunion du conseil des ministres à
l'elysée fera probablement le point sur
ces opérations de lutte contre la
pollution en bretagne
une tâche dont il a été chargé il y a
près d'un mois ce conseil des ministres
fois sera essentiellement consacrée à
l'étude de quatre dossiers
les résultats du conseil européen de
copenhague la préparation du prochain
budget de la france la situation au
proche orient et la situation économique
et sociale
une réunion du gouvernement qui a été
préparée dès cet après midi à l'elysée
le premier ministre monsieur raymond
barre en effet été reçu par le président
de la république dès la fin du conseil
demain le premier ministre se plongera
d'ailleurs dans le dossier social
monsieur raymond barre en effet recevoir
en quinze jours où près de trois
semaines
tous les syndicats français les marches
de l'elysée syndicats et organisations
professionnelles vont grimper celle de
l'hôtel matignon le premier ministre
veut procéder à un vaste tour d'horizon
afin d'examiner les possibilités de
faire repartir la politique
contractuelle
les entretiens vont s'échelonner sur une
période de deux à trois semaines
premier rendez vous demain à 9h30
andré bergeron de force ouvrière
vendredi à 9 heures 30 ce sera le tour
edmond maire de la cfdt et mardi 25
avril à 16 heures celui le georges seeds
le calendrier sera précisé dans les
jours qui viennent les organisations
professionnelles syndical des cols et
représentants patronaux ainsi que la fed
vont venir voir le premier ministre de
quoi vont ils parler et bien bien sûr du
smic très certainement de l'amélioration
des conditions de travail de la durée du
travail est bien aussi de la liberté des
prix que désire le patronat la politique
20 ans monsieur roger chinaud le
président du groupe parlementaire de
l'udf a été reçue ce matin durant une
heure par le chef du gouvernement
à sa sortie de matignon monsieur gino a
estimé qu'il lui paraissait tout à fait
normal qu'il y ait un vote des députés
sur la politique du gouvernement en
début de législature mais on ne sait pas
encore si monsieur bart engagera la
responsabilité de son équipe le 19 avril
devant l'assemblée nationale
une décision qui sera vraisemblablement
prise lors du conseil des ministres de
la semaine prochaine du côté des
communistes un démenti aujourd'hui pour
henry fils bas du comité central du
parti communiste
on ne peut pas parler d'une contestation
de la stratégie du pc il ya bien sûr
les interrogations écrit monsieur fils
bas mais les innombrables réunions qui
se sont tenues à ce jour de ses
innombrables réunions se dégage une
approbation massive de la politique du
parti
une thèse qui est contestée dans le
silence à l'intérieur des cellules et
publiquement par certains intellectuels
du parti où certains anciens membres du
parti communiste français
je vous prie de m'excuser bref coup de
téléphone
nous allons pouvoir continuer
normalement je vous le disais une thèse
qui est contestée dans le silence à
l'intérieur des cellules ou bien public
temps disons par certains intellectuels
du parti où certains anciens membres du
parti communiste français ainsi pour
roger garaudy qui jusqu'en 1970 à siéger
au bureau politique du pc avant d'en
être exclu
les militants aujourd'hui remettent en
cause l'attitude de leur mouvement
durant les six derniers mois
roger garaudy le réflexion porte sur
quatre grands problèmes
il ya des questions profondes qui sont
posées elle débarque dans le plus
profond qui s'imposait dans l'histoire
du parti d'abord première question est
mise en cause dans la discussion la
ligne même du parti c'est à dire une
politique d'intégration modèle de
croissance du capitalisme actuel
tout le programme commun étaient fondées
sur cette exaspération du modèle de
croissance ce qui amène une intégration
du parti au système deuxièmement je
crois qu'elle joue un très grand rôle
le reniement 1976 par le parti de sa
dénonciation pendant trente ans de
l'illusion nucléaire à partir du moment
où on accepter de se rallier à ce
système de défense qui repose dans les
mains d'un homme d'un très petit groupe
d'hommes on coupe la voie à toute espèce
démocratie
troisièmement ce que l'on reproche je
crois aux artistes d'amener une très
fausse politique d'unité les militants
sentent bien qu'on est sorti de la
grande voie traditionnelle et très forte
consiste à vouloir faire une idée
d'abord à la base dans des comités du
sinn de quartier université etc
alors qu'on a fait simplement un des
pourparlers entre états-majors au sommet
et même du point de vue théorique une
erreur fondamentale a été commise au
point de vue du point de vue de l'unité
on n'a pas fait une analyse sérieuse des
couches sociales de ce que j'appelais
quand j'étais exclue pour re communisme
prématuré un bloc historique nouveau
entre la classe ouvrière
les ingénieurs techniciens et cadres et
enfin la structure même du parti est
mise en cause
on veut bien laisser parler les
militants à la base c'est la démocratie
mais à condition que cela n'influe pas
sur les décisions
du sommet et c'est le centralisme je
crois que ce sont les quatre points sur
lesquels un redressement est possible si
le débat va jusqu'au bout et qui
permettrait de faire renaître
l'espérance les trois avocats français
qui devant le tribunal de stuttgart
mannheim assure la défense de m klose
croissants ont refusé de se présenter à
l'audience ce matin
les défenseurs de l'avocat de bader et
de ses amis refusent de participer au
débat aussi longtemps qu'ils devront
satisfaire à une fouille corporelle
avant d'entrer dans la salle d'audience
cela n'a pas empêché le procès de se
poursuivre aujourd'hui
les forces israéliennes ont entamé leur
repli dans le sud du liban
au fur et à mesure que l'armée
israélienne recule vers ses bases des
soldats des forces des nations unies les
remplace aux points stratégiques
l'opération menée aujourd'hui n'est que
la première phase du retrait israélien
la deuxième phase est prévue pour
vendredi prochain il semble toutefois
établi maintenant que l'armée
israélienne gardera quelques positions
dans le sud du libre ou bien c'est une
provocation ou bien mon mari est malade
telle a été la première réaction
aujourd'hui madame shevchenko les
douches de ce haut fonctionnaire
soviétique il dit sous secrétaire
général de l'onu qui a décidé hier de ne
plus retourner en urss voie d'affichage
tchenko annoncé qu'il était en désaccord
monsieur shevchenko triste annoncé
qu'ils étaient en désaccord avec son
gouvernement
pour l'instant il n'a pas demandé
l'asile politique aux états unis mais un
télégramme m'apprendre que l'union
soviétique vient d'élever une
protestation énergique auprès du
gouvernement des états unis au sujet de
cette affaire
union soviétique accuse les services
secrets américains d'être mêlés je la
cite au piège méprisable tendue aux
diplomates soviétiques l'aristocratie
londonienne et depuis ce matin en
révolution pour la première fois depuis
plus de 150 ans il n'a pas pu s'y était
possible aujourd'hui de se faire servir
une traditionnelle tasse de thé aux
alentours de 4,5 heures au claridge l'un
des plus prestigieux hôtels de la
capitale britannique le c'est l
abstinence forcer une abstinence parce
que les employés d'hôtels sont en grève
et ils sont en guerre parce que l'on à
renvoyer l'un des leurs alors devinez
pourquoi on l'a renvoyé justement parce
qu'il avait bu une tasse de thé pendant
le service seulement voilà les employés
des grands hôtels en
glay aujourd'hui estime que la sanction
est vraiment exagéré il pourrait décider
de tous se mettre en grève
londres claude gagnaire
voilà le portier du clarisse ne m'a pas
ouvert la porte parce que je ne dois pas
être vêtu comme un gentleman il le fait
pourtant à d'autres le claridge est un
des hôtels des plus fameux du monde
honorable et onéreux établissement
londonien qui en cent soixante trois ans
d'existence a reçu les clients les plus
respectueux les plus fameux mais n'a
jamais connu l'ignominie d'une grève
or et pour une tasse de thé l'hôtel
aujourd'hui est pratiquement paralysé et
le mouvement pourrait bien s'étendre à
la majorité des hôtels de londres il ya
quelques jours un cuisinier de 19 ans a
été licencié pour incompétence
allons donc le cuisinier de roissy cela
fait 18 mois que je travaille et on ne
m'a fait que trois remarques d'avoir
pris une tasse de thé pendant le travail
d'avoir trop salée une ratatouille et
enfin d'avoir eu une dispute avec un
colère mais avait vendu à prix une tasse
de thé oui je les fais mais pas pendant
le travail
les repas étaient terminées nous dit
edwige dont les employés demandent
aujourd'hui la réintégration et pour lui
la vraie raison est qu'il est délégué
syndical et qu'il cherchait à organiser
les employés de l'hôtel alors depuis
hier soir une bonne partie des
cuisiniers femme de chambre ou mme sont
en grève pour demander la réintégration
du délégué et la reconnaissance par la
direction du syndicat
et parmi ses employés beaucoup de
français et vous êtes engrais oui nous
sommes en grève mais c'est pour soutenir
quelqu'un qui a été renvoyé
comme nous sommes on voulait tous
solidaires qu'êtes vous venu faire ici
en angleterre si venus apprendre
l'anglais et on vient d'apprendre
l'anglais on se retrouve en grève
s'étaient déjà licenciés en france est
vue voilée engrais ici mais est-ce que
vous êtes surpris par ces grèves en
angleterre vous en tant que français oui
disons que ça change de la france parce
que c'est beaucoup plus calme en france
les défilés dans la rue sinon on reste
devant le lieu de
manifestation est ce pour faire voir aux
gens mais on ne défile pas dans la rue
c'est beaucoup plus calme
y a pas de bagarre ni rien avec avec la
police la direction pour l'instant
refuse de parler elle va pourtant bien
devoir négocier car la solidarité est en
train de jouer
le syndicat des travailleurs municipaux
compte quelques 1000 membres dans
l'industrie hôtelière de londres et ils
seraient prêts eux aussi à débrayer
quelques fournisseurs ont suivi le
mouvement et demain l'hôtel ne sera pas
livrée en neuf
les légumes etc la direction a dû
annuler tous les banques et certaines de
800 personnes pour la semaine à venir
une perte considérable
tout cela pour une tasse de thé et trop
de sel dans une ratatouille
du moins officiellement
les joueurs de bastia vont jouer demain
le match de leur saison au stade furiani
les corses vont tenter de se qualifier
pour la finale de la coupe de l'uefa
s'ils réussissent les joueurs de pierre
cahuzac rejoindront dans la légende des
clubs français finaliste d'une coupe
d'europe
reims et saint-etienne au match aller à
zurich les suisses l'avait emporté 3
buts à 2 bastia conserve donc toutes ses
chances
l'équipe corse a été composée
aujourd'hui demain soir hélas il y aura
de grands absents
l'arrière guesdon qui rend pas c'est par
case et donc a été suspendu et johnny
rep qui blessé a dû laisser la place aux
néo calédonien au sud
bastia donc contre les grasshoppers de
zurich demain soir à bastia mais aussi
en direct sur antenne 2 à partir de
20h30
il ya eu le rhythm and blues le soul
music et aujourd'hui il y a le discours
le discours d'une musique exclusivement
destiné à la danse ce n'est ni du rock
budget requis disons que ça mc de très
lointain rapport avec le temps comme le
disco c'est un piétinement un
balancement des anges cadencé par la
grosse caisse et de la contrebasse une
idée française qui a d'abord fait fureur
aux états unis avant bien sûr de revenir
avec du succès au bercail
les américains ont d'ailleurs baptisé ce
nouveau style de musique le french sand
alors georges bigot a voulu se rendre
compte exactement de ce qu'était le
disco et sur 7 sur cette musique
endiablée pardon que je vais vous
laisser ce soir je vous rappelle tout de
même qu'à 23h30 gérard holtz qui vous
présentera le dernier journal après les
dossiers de l'écran qui sont consacrés
ce soir à la situation en italie
je vous souhaite donc de passer une très
bonne soirée à demain laissons la place
ou prennent sens
les compositeurs et les orchestrateurs
français vont-ils colonisé l'amérique
ils ont vendu en 77 30 millions d'albums
disco hors des frontières et réalisé un
chiffre d'affaires de 120 milliards de
centimes
le billboard qui est la bible des
producteurs aux états unis donnent
actuellement sept titres français dans
les 40 premiers au hit parade pour
percer la carapace du marché américain
les compositeurs français ont dû prendre
des noms anglo saxons ils ont bu
habiller leur musique de textes anglais
et voyagez beaucoup aujourd'hui les
inventeurs du french sade non plus à
dissimuler leur nom ils sont admis c'est
le cas dalet constant dinos le pionnier
et le pape du french hard qui définit ce
nouveau style
franson et facile à définir relativement
facile c'est tout d'abord une mélodie
mélodies et il faut insister là dessus
ça démarrait avec des mélodies en mineur
ce qui caractérise une mélodie dit
européenne
l'ips méditerranéenne c'était donc la
bounce à cela venait sa douce
s'additionner à une grosse caisse qui
jouaient tous les temps tous les temps
et avec de belles harmonies toujours aux
mineurs et le tout con principe bien
réalisé
pour réaliser un disque dans l'esprit
disco c'est à dire extrêmement moderne
et dansant il faut compter un budget de
combien aux moyennes mais dans la bonne
mesure parce que quelque 25 millions
d'anciens francs
ça peut aller jusqu'à 30 millions ça
peut les dépasser la moyenne de 2,25
millions sur le chiffre à peu près exact
de ce qu'il faut faire un disque dit
discours ceux qui dansent ne se sont pas
trompés sur la nouveauté et la qualité
du frame sand et de jeunes auteurs qui
ont abandonné la chanson pour le disco
ont vécu une aventure enrichissante
on a vendu 4 millions de 45 tours à
travers le monde et plus de et plus d'un
million trois cent mille 30 33 tours
donc voilà c'est une c'est une très
belle aventure qui n'est pas un coup
parce que le deuxième album délivrance
est sorti maintenant il ya un mois et on
a vendu à peu près 300 mille albums sur
le monde mais ça fait seulement un mois
donc je pense que l' aventure va se
continuer pendant très longtemps encore
pour mac centraux du groupe voyage des
airs romantiques mais dès que le piano
est abandonné pour le synthétiseur et
les consoles sophistiqués ils pensent à
l'efficacité
l'amérique ne fait pas de cadeau enfin
il faut tout de même pas se leurrer
parce que mon savoir je te réponds moi
pour gagner beaucoup d'argent il faut il
faut environ quatre fois plus aux états
unis parce que là bas il ya beaucoup de
taxes c'est beaucoup d'avocats riel et
beaucoup de choses le prince des effets
spéciaux c'est jean michel jarre tiberio
wagner avait connu l'électronique qu'est
ce que vous pensez qu'il s'en serait
servi
oui sans doute les synthétiseurs permet
de de d'intégrer le réalisme par exemple
la sonde pluie ou d'un son tonnerre où
elles sont de locomotive avec un certain
romantisme c'est à dire d'une façon
musicale donc sans doute qu'il l'aurait
utilisé
les nouveaux compositeurs passent plus
de temps dans les avions que dans la
solitude de leur atelier
ils ont de bonnes raisons de faire
autant de chemins que leur musique
on suit la carrière du liszt à partir du
moment où il est créé là je suis piano
jusqu'au on va dans le studio
on veut tous suivre parce qu'en fait on
ne peut plus confié ses intérêts les
yeux fermés en lisant bombay la maison
dit vous allez mener pour mouvoir senard
résultat de cette promotion de
l'engouement général pour le disco
hollywood et le cinéma se sont émus et
la fièvre du samedi soir est en train de
gagner l'europe
l'acteur danseur john travolta
cristallise un phénomène social dont on
peut penser qu'il durera plus longtemps
qu'une mode
une vingtaine de films disco sont en
préparation et ne vous étonnez pas de
retrouver le nom des compositeurs
français au gnl